so i started the firm out of my kitchen
and
really it's grown really fast over the
last
four and a half five years since i
started it
[Music]
sophie alcorn thank you for being on my
show 20 minute leaders how are you
hi michael i'm doing great it was really
awesome to be here thank you so much
well thank you for for giving me your
generous time even
in the late evening i really appreciate
it sophie
who are you where are you even calling
from right now
uh i am calling you from mountain view
california i live in silicon valley san
francisco bay area so very close to
stanford
and i am an immigration attorney i'm a
top
10 california immigration
lawyer certified specialist by the state
bar
and my law firm elkhorn immigration law
focuses
on uh startup immigration so it's great
to be here
wonderful okay so there's so much to
talk about before we get to startup
immigration
what is immigration law and its essence
and obviously this is something that
you know immigration ever since you know
and the past
decade i think has been some has been
somewhat of a heated topic
in this country as i'm starting to learn
give me a little bit of context as to
why this is such a complicated matter
and what is immigration law
i love that question that's such a
brilliant i love starting with the
philosophical
uh immigration is
people want to move we're on this globe
and the land doesn't come with walls
but we build them and then we want to
get past them
and so immigration law is helping people
navigate
those walls and borders and
it's an especially interesting time to
think about it
not just because of all the political
things that are happening in covid but
also
um augmented reality virtual reality
you know future of work like what is
immigration going to be in the future
so immigration you know as the world is
becoming more globalized
you know as a young entrepreneur i'm
imagining that there should be a pretty
linear correlation the more globalized
the world is
the easier it will be for people to move
between countries
now of course i'm imagining you're
specializing in the us but is this the
case or is it big or because it doesn't
seem so from the news that it's becoming
easier as the world gets more globalized
well certainly in the united states it's
becoming harder
and other countries over the last couple
decades have
also been on a path towards
increased restrictionism
and xenophobia which might be a backlash
to globalization um
for people in the know it it may be
easier than ever
um but it's not
obvious in every situation right so
uh what is that what is the context of
immigration law
you know within the sphere of silicon
valley
because it's it isn't the same as or not
no it's different and it's wonderful
i think it's so fun i love
uh the brilliant minds that come here
from all over the world drawn by
places like stanford berkeley google
apple
um people are so excited to come here
and start companies
and meet venture capitalists and so
i'm thrilled because i get to talk to
brilliant people every day who are
working on
such diverse pursuits and topics
so immigration law is different here
than in the rest of the country and i
practiced in different areas
geographically
and in some of my prior legal
incarnations it was more about
supporting undocumented people or
victims of domestic violence
or children who had been separated from
their families
human trafficking there's lots of really
intense
things that go on with respect to
immigration that are
you know very important
and legally speaking
as a practitioner it's very challenging
because
the law is stacked against people in
these situations often
and it can definitely lead to burnout
and compassion fatigue
which i experienced and and so
i welcome the opportunity that i have
now
to work with really bright people
to learn from my clients as
entrepreneurs
who think about disruption and system
change
and yes i can do some of that pro bono
work right now
but i'm also looking at ways to create
more
systemic change and reform and to bring
what you know what we can
model here out to the rest of the
country and potentially the world
sure so take me back a little bit
because it doesn't seem like this is
just something
somebody stumbles on to and says oh okay
i'm gonna be an immigration
an immigration attorney and i'm gonna
i'm gonna found my own
uh you know my own firm a very a very
very successful firm in silicon valley
in
of all places so give me your background
how do you even get
sucked into this world so
my dad was an immigration lawyer my mom
is an immigrant from germany
she was his client and
so i grew up in an immigrant
household with a dad who was
in the 80s loving being like david
versus goliath and
and doing all these crazy deportation
battles and being in the courtroom he
was a former marine
and he loved the adrenaline of that and
he had his own immigration law firm in
southern california and so i grew up
you know we would have people over for
dinner and it was normal to have
uh ukrainian nuclear
physicists and vietnamese businessmen
and you know artists and singers
so he my my parents definitely
cultivated that
appreciation for just getting to know
people from all over the world
and um i worked for my dad
and from compassion fatigue kind of
burned out after a couple years
and um that's
that's the the time in my life when um i
had my kids
and through um my marriage ended up
back in silicon valley where you know my
ex and i had met at stanford and so we
came back here for his job and i was a
stay-at-home mom
for several years didn't have a
professional network in the bay area
just
you know maybe a handful
handful of friends from college um who i
was still a little bit connected with
but um
my this is a lot it was a crazy story uh
basically my dad passed away
unexpectedly i
had argued with him about disinherit
like i wanted to disinherit myself
not knowing that he was going to die wow
but then he did
and i didn't know he was going to
disinherit me but he did
and um and then like
my um i i got to the
the point of my prior marriage where it
also wasn't going to work anymore so i
was a
mom to a toddler and preschooler who
didn't have a career
and was trying to figure out a way to
pay rent in silicon valley
and i really wanted to be an
entrepreneur and i thought about going
to coding school
but it seemed like that would
maybe not be the quickest way to get
into the ecosystem
wow so i started the firm out of my
kitchen
and really it's grown really fast over
the last
four and a half five years since i
started it so you start the firm out of
your kitchen you say i could go to
i could go to a coding school i mean all
right i'll just start the i'll start a
law firm
give me a little bit of taste as to what
alcorn immigration law is today what is
this group
how many cases it is one of the most
well-known
firms in in the country for for
immigration law but
but what is that what's happening now
with it
well we've bootstrapped we have about a
team of 15
attorneys and paralegals uh we have a
distributed team across the country
which we've had for a while so that was
great to have in place pre-coveted we
kind of went digital
and we have helped thousands of
uh international individuals
from all over the world get visas and
green cards to live and work legally in
the states
we focus on entrepreneurs and investors
inventors researchers
engineers and
and from from the law firm base i've
started a podcast immigration law for
tech startups i'm a techcrunch
contributor with a weekly immigration
advice column dear sophie
wow and it's it's it's really fun
tell me a little bit about this column
so the techcrunch column
dear so yeah how does it work
so basically people write in their
immigration questions
and then every week i answer somebody's
questions with an in-depth
uh legal educational article about like
the technical details of immigration law
and it's uh
within the extra crunch brand that
techcrunch has
what is the most complicated part of
immigration law so
what are some things that you know
obviously the whole thing to
somebody who's not a lawyer is like it's
a black box that i have no idea how
anything over there works but but what
are some of the deep complexity that
that you have to deal with on a daily
basis
to help people get access to this
country
well the stories are are so
moving i mean just
within the last um just
like the last 24 hours the the people
i've spoken with like
a startup founder who won a bunch of
awards got stuck in canada
got denied her visa and is now trying to
figure out a way to come back in
and somebody really wants to hire her do
they start a company in canada
just so she can work there for a year
yeah and then um another startup founder
who's like trying to break away from his
company and he needs to lay the plan
to do it without jeopardizing his
current job
but his co-founder needs to be secure
but they're trying to get a contract
and they don't want to violate their
offer letter
or not you know or any like
non-disclosure
of confidential information stuff so how
do they start the company
without working there and without
violating that and then
so that was just the morning and then
you know somebody with a friend who's
like
trying to have the wife and kid live
here
but they don't have a way to stay then
somebody's stuck in india working in a
big tech company
who the government is really
scrutinizing whether she's
extraordinary or not
and then somebody else who just found
out from a big company that their visas
got denied
but this means that since their last
status expired like
four months ago that they have to
basically leave immediately they don't
know if their company is going to bring
them back
in if the company cares enough so how do
they find a way to stay
that was just today i didn't even like
roll back for the last
24 hours wow that's just that's
unbelievable so
i mean is this also the best part of the
job
getting to hear everybody's stories and
getting exposed to
because the all these these are like big
life decisions right like where am i
going to be
live this is not just you know
this is serious stuff it's really
serious stuff the best thing is winning
um the best thing is like taking the
impossible situation
and transforming it and somebody getting
their sense of freedom for the first
time
of something like this well um
take the h-1b visa for example which is
a very common working visa for
professionals
under obama and prior administrations
it was approved about 93 percent of the
time and maybe five percent of the time
there was something called a request for
evidence
under the current administration the
last statistic
i saw the approval rate declined
was it 93 now it was like hovering at 70
percent
really and the request for evidence had
gone up
from like 5 to like 30 percent
so it's gotten very
intense um
but we are still winning those
i cannot guarantee any future outcome
ethically
but uh historically speaking looking at
past data
uh we have been winning h1bs like 97
wow okay yeah that's incredible and so
is the engagement with the client is the
does it
is the lifetime of it just that you know
that one act of getting that visa or is
it something that's ongoing and you need
to have continuous support
and engagement with them yeah well so
we're focusing on the startup ecosystem
so we start with the founder
who's often an immigrant get their
immigration situation figured out
and then stick with them through the
raises
the growth and basically to bring on
whole
engineering teams often in deep tech
and for any one individual it's like
a visa a green card and then citizenship
but they might have several different
types of visas before they ever get a
green card
right and so you know a lot when there's
when there are different uh
firms that are helping startups grow a
lot of the times they'll take let's say
equity for pro
and then do so and join the company's
venture
instead of a down payment it doesn't
sound like this is something that might
that
could be fitting perhaps to to this
model does it happen or is this all
engagement with the people you're but
you're just knowledgeable about the
company that they're starting
um well because you
asked uh i have not historically been
able to
do that but i'm actually trying to
recruit
an mba intern volunteer ideally from a
place like stanford
who can help write the business plan for
the immigrant focused accelerator
to form that we have vc interest for
and with that structure in place we
would then be able to
do like immigration for equity sort of
thing
wow okay that's a very very cool give me
a little bit of
of higher context as to where we're
headed
and i mean immigration it's such a
complicated concept on its own but
where where is this whole ecosystem
headed and what
needs to change for things to to get
better if they don't need to get better
a lot of places in the world have
realized
because they have not been as
economically privileged as the united
states has been in recent decades
that immigration is actually great
for the economy for creating jobs
and for increasing the quality of life
of their citizens
so in the next five ten years
i think the us is at a at a critical
point
and i want to help usher us forward
into appreciating the value and
contributions of immigrants and
i think that that could be a real key to
getting out of the economic situation
that we currently find ourselves in
because immigrants create jobs
right it's hard to be an immigrant right
no
i mean and so it sounds like it's mainly
contests in
in a place like the united states
because of
nationalism and and some arguments about
the economy
at the end you're seeing it very from a
humane perspective of
right i mean whatever your motivation is
like if you just want to talk about
money immigrants add money
like if you want to talk about human
rights it's the right thing to do
if you want to talk about um
kindness and loving your neighbor and
that like if we help one person it helps
us all
like we can have it that way too so it's
a win-win
so five years ago starting out in a
in your kitchen now you're running a
15-person
law firm and that's that's recognized as
one of the top four immigration law
where what what's
what's next where are you headed oh so
many things
um i need to hop off this call in a
couple minutes because i'm having
my first diplomatic zoom meeting with a
minister
of a country to talk about their
innovation economy and supporting
uh women and children through innovation
um so it's really exciting that the
accelerators on there
i founded a non-profit called the
community for global innovation
we're looking for tech companies to take
the pledge that they are opening
open to hiring international graduates
and won't
hold that against them the sky is the
limit
i love it i love it okay so i have to
release you to go talk to the minister
of innovation but before that i need
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
and why those three words okay
uh driven i think you know why
uh adventurous because i love having new
adventures and trying new things
and silly because i'm actually really
quite
silly i love it sophie thank you so so
much for the
for your time and and best of luck okay
best of luck winning every case and
helping every person fulfill yeah
they're personal
personal or professional thank you very
much thank you appreciate you
thank you so much bye